hey what up guys good morning today's
very special day and I'll show you why
it's kid cause birthday what's up bad
guys birthday right there that's you
might recognize goes on his Batman and
kid Chi was always Superman doctor I
know I know
greatest gift ever
just saying what up guys welcome back to
episode 8 of Pokemon go vlogs today
we're gonna be going hang up the phone
like we told you guys last week we're
also we gotta do some awesome evolutions
we're gonna catch some eggs and we're
gonna be talking about the buddy system
get excited
all right guys we got really wet zone if
you go outside it's just extremely
quality I'm raining and windy so looks
like fun whether that's preferred but we
did spot a Pikachu take a look at that
alright guys so we just took pictures
make pika - which is pretty slick and
now we're gonna be walking through the
casino the sick thing about this place
is that you actually have an indoor
walkway so we're gonna be checking that
out they have a bunch of stops
we gotta learn them up and hopefully
catch some awesome pool yeah guys so
it's so bad outside that we can't even
go outside to lure up this clubs that
are on the outside but we're gonna try
to get go indoors through this little
walkway yeah and we love this possible
we can read from inside
alright guys who are at the place it's
super loud because we're at the food
court surrounded by people eating and we
just ran till Vulpix which doesn't say
that we got see if I can catch them
I ran there
there is as you can see but we're gonna
eat right now we have the two spots
learn
we're hitting them both and boys gotta
have a croissant
so that my chair
there's boys tarragon
get himself
alright guys so we just lost that Vulpix
but here's a chance for redemption a max
was how much 618 CP minus 15 CP 680 is
pretty decent let's see the IV's that's
fine though you see candy I want to say
that my nickname for this channel is
Nana Mac and he keeps calling me by my
real name which is going on it's kind of
like that whole rush hour to think Chris
Ducker
check this out
yeah first get in here all the time guys
pretty penny
Vulpix Rhyhorn that make it like a tit
hi guys we're gonna do a caricature
right now
I don't like you pick any pulp bot I see
someone getting Pikachu over there we're
or just we're just sitting here we're
both gonna be at the picture and we're
hopeful things had one pole one in here
we're gonna see it for you to shoot
possum about she likes me but it's a bit
complicated so we might do a Pikachu
that's an extra-large just dump it fill
your IVs man what are your so it's
finished and we did get our favorite
Pokemon you'll see it reminds you to see
all the reveal
mute to end it oh boy just look copycat
nice buns Olin has been nice enough to
give us some free tokens play some of
the game so compete goes that is
challenging Anna back to air hockey
let's see what happen I've been here I'm
gonna win long story short I'm sorry to
ruin it for you guys all right guys 6 5
6 5 for me I can take this right now
let's see the Lions got a nice scarf
going but I think I know this is a dance
man
all right guys or gods
don't look at me okay so after goals and
clearly cheated to win that air hockey
match what we're going to do now is
compete in basketball the arcade game
gonna take them out hurry up roll don't
want a few putting in your tokens they
want to see some real action
in liquids all and he's in the zone he's
in the fun zone
what do we got what do we go oh here we
got 90 90 points I don't like the city
to feel bad
I doubt it
can I beat it probably not you put it in
a nice try bucks so you're gonna
practice round
all right that's not won in yet
27 points so I again unfortunately he
did not get overtime look at this so we
just won a whole bunch of tickets from
some slot machine game I don't know I
just press three buttons and like 250
tickets came out or something crazy like
every winter a lottery realize well 50
guys
so I'm thinking like just get that
pirate sword yeah yeah we're gonna get
the Pirates are
one piece alright guys so we just came
out of the fun zone
yeah we've got a good time we got this
awesome caricature yeah we're favorite
Pokemon here and you 240 or we'd look at
those teeth look Mewtwo and did all my
favourite Pokemon because he's the best
he could be anything his potential is
unlimited yes
okay we also got a pirate we got a
pirate sword eyes with the tickets we
turn we earn like hold our tickets and
then we have something it's left over so
we got these small balls these small
ball
what up
yeah guys so I think I definitely ended
up like winter for today yeah the games
we played
I guess although I beat them into
American football camp he got one
however we did have a good time at the
fun zone we like this event apparently
they're gonna have some more events
coming up soon and if they do we'll
definitely let you guys know yeah guys
just look looking at this from you too
though look how awesome it is and she
did end up being able to get the Mewtwo
which was sick and Boyd and his precious
ditto I named this Anna Mac I guess it
was a very fun day for Pokemon and we
had a blast at the fun zone we also went
along and caught a Sidra and my first
liquor tongue
I also evolved my best ever Clefairy
which became ridiculously strong
I also evolved my best ever Eevee but
surprise surprise it turn into a Jolteon
aside from that we got some decent eggs
like otters from dinner and but nothing
amazing the buddy system has helped me
get almost three candies for Charmeleon
although it's a slow process but better
than nothing and certain pokémon like
Geodude and Pikachu only need one
kilometre per egg so you can fly through
those evolution
alright guys hope you guys enjoyed the
episode until next time see you space
cowboys